you know we were talking about julius
randle picking up that
nighttime shooting routine from kobe
bryant it started
as a rookie for randall they were in
dallas playing
and at the hotel he ran into brian at
the elevator
and brian said to him as we watch
randall raise up and knock down the
three
brian said to randall at the elevator
where are you going
randall said hey i'm from dallas i'm
going to see my family for dinner he
goes
no you're not you're coming to the gym
with me and that was the genesis
of julius randle's nighttime shooting
routine hey when the mama says you're
coming with me vince
you're going to go yeah plans of change
have changed sorry family
one possession one shot one possession
rebound and get out in transition
and that's what the raptors did right
there boy a catch and shoot three
right down the pipe for julius randle
tried to get a little get back at the
other end barrett with the board
and the push
back out to randall catch and shoot
three on the way again
two for two from deep and the knicks
lead by five
you see julia just catches it one two
plants it and
lets it fly i mean there's bullock out
to randall
still guarded by annan obi raising up
for three and another
three ball man julius randle three for
four from deep
bryant said to him as we watch randall
raise up and knock down the three brian
set to randall at the elevator
and birch with the great pass to sayakam
just off the mark
bullock goes the screen randall pulls up
from downtown
and knocks down another three ball this
guy
is hotter than fish grease here in the
first half
kaiden is watching all stars you gotta
be on point
get crowd pulling on the catch on the
three ball back out to randall guarded
by an inoby
they shade him in to help with van bleet
it didn't matter
[Applause]
see here just step back and just
yes van fleet i see you